oh we are and our parliamentarians are
consumed with the question of how brexit
is supposed to make Britain great again
austerity has been all but forgotten
even though for most people
cuts to public services local government
and welfare have a far greater impact on
their daily lives than the details of a
negotiation with Brussels the facts are
stark support workers say the closure of
youth centres and cuts to policing are
linked to the rise in violent crime the
lack of public housing has led to a
crisis of homelessness the poorest
families with children many of them
working have been sinking deeper into
poverty so when the government says
these cuts are necessary to balance the
books
make no mistake as to who is paying the
price and when the government says
brexit is about what kind of country we
want to live in I fear we already have
the answer so what are you asking for I
would like us to pay more attention to
what's already happening in the country
that a problem what already has total
sovereignty over which is austerity
that's continuing how people I'd like it
to change I would like an end to
austerity and I would like us to start
investing in our services again in
investment that could actually help
create employment that would encourage
private sector investment and it would
help grow the economy because frankly
austerity has failed
see I think I agree with you that BRICS
has become very old consuming and as you
just heard me say a moment ago I think
that a huge part of that was because we
were so underprepared for the
eventualities of brexit that we've been
running around chasing our tails ever
since I do I agree with you about that
yeah so I share your content I also
share your concerns about things like
the cutting of youth centres and things
like that because I think that those
decisions were very ill for our when I
look at austerity and where cuts have
been made and where spending has been
protected I get very frustrated for
example at things like the foreign the
foreign aid spending which has been
protected in the face of the things that
you've just been talking about so a
police officers etc being cut I think
that was a very wrong decision but if we
were going to have austerity and it to
be affecting people's everyday alive
that things like International
Development were protected from that so
I would
to see the international development
that protection removed and I would
actually like to see some thoughts going
into how are we going to protect things
like or recreate things like the youth
centers and the youth services etc
because I do agree with you that they
are failing but what I do think about
austerity is that it has been very
necessary because it's just basic common
sense that you cannot have a country
which continues spending where we're
more then it's making that's just not
common sense but Michelle economists
call this zombie economics because
they're ideas that have been tried out
over and over again and they've never
worked and then yet they keep getting
resurrected you know and the evidence is
that having debt and having a deficit
spending it does not necessarily harm
economic growth that that's Evan can I
just put way coming Majid show you some
statistics because this is what with
we're talking and I think we kind of
agree Michelle I mean International
Development spending an aid is another
another topic and we don't agree about
that but just to look at this this is
food bank usage it's gone up 418 percent
since 2012 and this is homelessness
homelessness has gone up 169 percent and
I sometimes wonder how it is that we
have all decided to be content to live
in a society where the poorest are
suffering so much I want to agree with
this point that where that noise raised
and thank you for raising it
I think austerity has gone too far and I
also endorse what you just said there
about economics I think the Keynesian
model versus the classical model of
economics that the jury is out and
that's why I'm not an ideologue if we
have growth through investment funding
through the state investing in our
infrastructure that can also raise tax
revenue and raise more for the Treasury
as well I mean we will remember that
Treasury secretary said there's no more
money left when the coalition government
came in I supported what I believe was
an emergency austerity that was needed I
think now as well as the majority of the
British public I think I'm with them
then it's gone too far in it all we need
to do is just take a cursory glance at
our country look at the rising
homelessness that you mentioned look at
the rise and spike in violent crime
across the country look at the NHS now
it's creaking at the seams but most
worrying of all for me because it's
something I care passionately about is
that with the state of our mental health
services and the rising suicide rates of
young men the biggest killer of young
men in this country isn't gang crime
and terrorism it's suicide territory
well it's related to I believe and of
course it's up for debate a lack of a
care for mental health and a lack of a
social care right and I unless we put
the funding where it's needed we're
gonna witness something tragic and that
is our young men continuing to kill
themselves there is no way around that
it requires money and then finally look
at prisons and the state of our prisons
and crime and drug ridden prisons that
we have we've got to move on before I
know what Nick wants to come in but
let's just look at the public's view on
this and the stats regarding this sixty
sixty six percent I think on the public
believe that cuts have gone too far of
course nine percent say not far enough
and eighty percent say about right just
need to say that the reason I has said
more money will be spent on the
provision of mental health care and I
don't know that we should base
everything necessarily on people using
food banks but as we started this
edition of the pledge by me explaining
to you that I am far brighter than the
rest of you I'm gonna give you first a
history lesson so I wonder if we go back
to November 2015 and hear from George
Osborne if our country doesn't bring the
deficit down the deficit could bring our
country down again and that's why for
the Economic Security every family in
Britain we must hold our nerve that was
the then Chancellor history lesson over
now class pick up your pencils for the
math lesson and let's look at some
charts over the last eight years the
government have reduced that deficit by
one hundred and nine billion pounds from
nearly a hundred and fifty billion
pounds to just under forty billion
pounds over the same period unemployment
has fallen from seven point nine percent
to four point four percent it's now at
record lows and the number of people
living in households where all members
had never worked now stands at five
hundred and thirteen thousand and Oldham
and in a report this week we learned
that since the be day not be down in
that sense since brexit day around a
thousand people have found work every
single day so so we like what I would
say to that if you look at how that the
their debt has been tackled if you look
at the creation of jobs if you don't
have it that way after work how would
you do it real wage growth as well how
not see it and that sounds great why are
we imagine if you're one of those people
watching now who's found employment
there's one of those thousand people
every day it doesn't sound great effort
number of working families are now
living in poverty how would you do it so
that's my point that being unemployment
is now not taking people T we need we
need wage increases we need wage degrees
in the public sector we need private
sector growth we need stable jobs not
zero hours she's right she's right and
economy and we need we need GDP growth
we need higher tax revenue so we can get
our public spending back to a
sustainable level so we can provide
essential public services just look at
the images of litter I'm not even
talking about youth services mental
collect what can I just said to
translate that math lesson thank you
though unemployment is falling of course
wages have stagnated and the cost of
living has gone up and of course that I
don't only need to mention the prices of
property and rent has gone up as a
result so it that doesn't give us the
full picture I think the country is
still going through a bit of a depressed
stage if you look at the states of
homelessness as a symbol of that it
symbolizes where we are at the moment
what we saw from that graph was as you
bring down the debt you know you are
cutting essential services and that is
that is the inevitable trade-off it's
fun oh it is I mean you look at what
councils budgets have been slashed in
half and we let's hear from that see
what the Home Office has said they
actually saying that you know they are
trying to keep a basic minimum of
service the government has provided a
strong and comprehensive settlement that
is increasing this is policing funding
our new serious violence strategy will
put a stronger focus on steering young
people away from violence while
continuing to ensure the strongest
possible law enforcement in response his
homelessness no one should have to ever
sleep rough on our streets and we are
determined to have the numbers by 2022
and eradicate it by 2027 so they
recognize there's a problem they
recognize that austerity has led to sort
of social you know lack of the mission
the word that's what I'm here for
shows right why are we finding 14
billion pounds of oversee to prop up the
government with a deal with the DUP
we've got money when we want it you're
making her change to the people out
there on these food banks if he's just
been banging on about money I may need
to stay in power she shook on magic
money trees yeah what is there it was
there